Well.
Well,
well go to your mom's house,
Christina.
MMM.
Tribulations by sounds made the beat.
Hmm.
Genes.
What do you got coming up?
Well,
my one night or tour is almost complete.
I have two more dates.
October 23rd in Indianapolis,
mortise comedy club.
October 24th Cincinnati.
Alright,
go bananas.
You know,
I'm going to try to replicate the Cincinnati far too.
I'm going to be eating a lot of high,
high fiber things and trying to recreate that special moment.
We'll see if it happens live.
Yeah.
We'll see.
I may have to put the microphone to my,
why don't you just have a second fixed Mike for the whole show down there.
You know,
why aren't you my agent?
Yeah.
To put this in my writer.
Well you,
where are you going to be at?
Good Banana Galvin,
Anna.
Call Mikey and ask him if they could tie one.
Yeah.
Maybe like have it just,
you know what I mean?
Like
anal level.
Yeah.
For the whole show.
If you pace it stays with you.
Wow.
Or just hire a PA or a little person.
Yeah,
that'd be great.
There you go.
Now you're sinking.
Think people work.
Yeah.
We're in boxes right now for this show,
by the way.
I don't care.
That's how we roll on the cigarette home today.
It's been chaos is boring.
December 9th and 10th,
a Dcm province,
Washington DC,
district of Columbia.
And that's,
that's it for now guys.
That's it.
Tommy,
what do you got?
Uh,
this weekend I'll be in Charlotte,
North Carolina,
uh,
not near my college home.
Uh,
I wanted to mention also that,
um,
Cox Comedy Club in San Francisco.
I'm going there next week.
Yeah.
And I'm just confirming this,
uh,
let's see right now if,
if Fox has this or not,
I don't see,
yeah,
I,
uh,
Sim.
Com comment,
carbs comical.
We added,
we added a second show Thursday.
Oh my gosh.
A,
the other one's sold out.
It's going to be it insanity to me.
A great,
huge room.
It's gonna be fun.
So if you're a man friend,
disco,
I think this is your only opportunity.
If you still want to come see me at Cox Comedy Club,
um,
get your tickets now.
Tom segura.com/shows right after that I go to another big city,
Jude or titties.
Um,
America is my favorite name.
Big Ted.
Apple is a,
is Robbie.
And then I have a few cities coming up before the year ends.
Raleigh's brawl.
He's North Carolina
and uh,
Lewin Lewisville,
um,
Kentucky home of top dog by the way.
First Place of top dog.
We need some better names.
We got,
we got to come up with Louisville and Raleigh.
Yeah.
And then I think after that filter up Delphia that's a great line now and fill
her up.
We added a fourth show at the Trocadero so please go to that if you're in
Philly.
And then west hairy balls,
beach,
Florida.
We'll see my,
um,
one of my final shows.
That's December,
early December.
And then I do new year's in mom.
Lando.
Oh my gosh.
What a crazy year this is.
This has been,
it's almost deliver.
Yeah.
When you do your calendar and you're like,
Holy Shit.
Yeah.
I'm well,
I'm on fucking like,
whoa.
Huh?
You know,
uh,
since all fast,
Huh?
Yeah.
Life goes fast.
Speaking of that.
Listen to this deep wrote.
That's how I talk,
I'm sure.
Yeah.
And also,
uh,
please don't forget to shop.
Yes.
Through our Amazon banner.
You go to your mom's house,
podcast.com.
You Click on the Mama's on banner,
you do your regular shopping and it gives a little kickback to the show.
Of course,
if you're a hardcore mother,
you take care of your children,
you can sign up for Patrion.
Put that down.
patrion.com/mom a new bonus episodes or core mom's only.
Yeah.
Like if your denim is so tight that you can barely breathe.
Patriots for you.
Yeah.
You get to hear us talk about behind the scenes stuff.
We go down memory lane.
It gets more hardcore too.
It gets way,
way worse or it gets way worse.
Worser way more.
Not Children friendly.
Uh,
we opened gifts,
Massey,
we answer emails.
It's like down the soundboard lane.
Yeah.
It's more for like the die hard.
Definitely.
It's a,
it's a different show.
It's,
it's kind of fun.
Yeah.
If we let our tits out on that show a little more.
X and Ted's are flying everywhere.
Literally.
I wish we could change our URL to dot.
Yeah.
C U M Babe.
What?
That's really gross.
I wanted to play this clip today,
but I,
the fucking files were all fucked up.
It
from the a she looks smart already.
It's pretty great.
She looks smart.
We'll see if we can start the show.
Are you ready to do this?
Oh Christ.
Right
all morning.
It has bothered me and bothered me.
It is eight at me and I'm just,
I'm still upset like as a mom,
I'm just mad.
I am mad man of the,
and,
and I'm going to give it a second.
I have an 11 year old daughter,
Aaliyah.
She loves that one.
Oh 4.5 radio station she loves and like whatever,
like I like the top hits.
Right?
I remember listening to the top hits when I was a kid,
like Britney spears and Christina Aguilera and backstreet boys and then seek,
and those were the top hits when I was just played,
which is fine.
I don't mind that.
Okay.
Um,
I usually listen to like the effect,
it's all Toby Mac newsboys is Christian music.
Oh No.
We'll get to it here in a second.
Oh No,
no.
Bring it in one month into this
role.
Go
Christina.
Okay.
This audio,
it looks like it's on two channels,
right?
And No.
Oh,
I see what's going on.
Hold on,
hold on,
hold on.
It looks like because this isn't here,
that's only playing in one,
but the rest of them are playing in too.
You understand what I'm saying?
No I don't,
but as long as you understand that's all that matters.
Can you hold,
can you correct it?
Yeah.
I want to say ms up for one second.
All right.
Um,
let's see if this works on both.
Oh No,
you did.
Yeah.
Oh,
that's loud.
That was really,
yeah.
So the,
um,
no ma'am,
ma'am.
Ma'Am,
ma'am,
ma'am.
Coffee tastes like a dirty ash tray.
It tastes like cigarettes.
Why do you have cigarette flavored coffee that you've purchased the coffee that
you can't live without?
It tastes like shit.
You didn't put any sweetener in it cause you're on your fucking weird diet,
right?
Yeah.
It tastes like assholes.
I don't know how you're drinking it.
Okay.
Oh,
it smells like a dirty ash tray.
oh.
Oh,
okay.
When I used to smoke,
that's why I can do that.
Yeah.
You like that?
I like it.
Uh Huh.
I don't drink coffee for flavor anymore.
No,
you don't.
No.
Just for torture,
for bowel torture as you know what you don't want to get again,
that Australian coffee,
Australian dream.
I know that Australian dream.
I want to go.
I want to order that again.
When you're talking about that shit was buttery and delicious,
and then to get that again,
my order it today show.
Okay,
we'll give a fuck.
I'll sit and I'm going to make it in that attack.
Like the stove press.
Yeah.
No,
that's not,
what's it called?
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Not the press.
No.
It's good value and style.
It's like the one my mom used to.
Yeah,
the rocket rocket fuel.
that was,
that's good.
That makes you shit a lot.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I'm so fucking dumb.
Okay.
I'm just making sure this is working,
right.
So are we.
So just so people know,
the reason that this is fucked up,
like where that opening clip was fucked up is normally we play these at a clips,
but the clips were like corrupted.
They were all fucked up.
They're all fucked up.
Not all of them,
just this Bank of clips.
So I have to play it from the source file,
which is basically play and pause and scrolling.
And that's why it sucks.
But this lady made this video that we played the first like 50 seconds of Ravi c
she's talking about,
she's driving her daughter to school or 11 year old daughter and her daughter
likes a certain radio station where they play today's hits.
And she's saying,
you know,
when I was a kid I liked that too.
I listened to my,
the hits,
then Britney Spears and in sync and all that,
whatever.
Right?
So now she's going on about,
um,
about what she's upset about.
Okay,
let's hear it.
That's what I usually have it on.
And my car.
Um,
I had just dropped Gabby off and,
and guys,
I could not believe what I was hearing.
Like this is on our,
our written local radio station.
This crap is being played.
I couldn't even believe the words that I was listening to.
I love how upset she was.
And as a mom,
as a mom,
it's my thing me like why is this on here?
Oh,
I'm sorry.
I'm going to collect myself because this is,
this is what our youth is being subjected to,
subjected to.
I agree.
So I feel when I hear top four and I'm going to read it to you dog shit,
and I want you do you thirsty?
Please grab a sprite.
My crips Lurkin don't die tonight.
I just want to dance with you baby.
Just don't move too fast.
I'm too crazy man.
Down down the AV and get shaded.
Take a Nigga mind off that big word we can get.
Fuck in the whip slide right back in the function.
One wrong word.
Start busting.
Put that on my Yankee hat.
Fritz Bandana Brown
guys.
I need some.
I've,
I've felt this way since I was 12 when I heard top 40 music.
I was like,
this is the dumbest shit.
It's a little different.
I think it was going on here.
I've ever heard.
Well,
she's upset because she thinks the lyrics are offensive,
but Brittany Spears was saying,
you know,
I just want to fuck you and hip.
She was pretending to be a teenage fuck queen.
Yeah,
right.
She was driving,
I just want to fuck you.
And that's all her songs.
Like,
well,
I was like,
hit me baby.
It's,
it's all about being an underaged fuck him.
That was her whole persona.
And that doesn't offend you.
Yeah.
Finger my privacy.
All those songs are about finger grabbed my pussy.
Basically.
It's Donald Trump.
Yeah.
Everyone fuck this whole,
and she's not bummed about that.
And like that was okay for her.
She should just make her kids listen to Christian music.
Like the dope daddy shooting in the kitchen.
Real nurse side.
Nigga never went to Paulie Wilson work or Barilla cocaine color of a
[inaudible].
I don't even know if I pronounced that right.
T scrap moving for the Da da,
but they shoot an every day round my mama and them way.
So we put a k
is it totally necessary to read every like couldn't you just paraphrase it a
couple of her?
Well I can't wait for someone to put this to a song.
They did
decided.
Okay,
well they also like the flow is incredibly,
they chopped it up so that it flows
and how to stay and that's for any Nigga say he got a problem with me now I'm
cribbing where I'm living.
Come and follow me.
Y'All
pull out the actual
actual,
you know,
I was forced to listen to top 40 music on my drive to the Dallas airport and I
actually disagree with her.
Finish my thoughts.
Yeah.
I actually think that top 40 music has become deeper then when I was a kid
because I was listening to the lyrics and they weren't as dumb as they used to
be.
It used to just be like,
tonight,
it's gonna be a good night tonight.
Tonight it's going to be fun.
Let's wet are pussies.
And finger are buttholes
and now it's like they had to talk about feelings.
They talk about sadness,
you know,
there's a little more nuance to top 40 I discovered this when I was forced to
listen to it in a car ride,
but I haven't heard,
by the way,
the Trump audio,
now that you're saying,
have you really,
I haven't heard it.
I thought I did.
I thought I had on the internet or he's,
he's inside of a bus with that Billy goat.
Okay.
Only heard bleeps.
You've heard it.
Oh yeah,
no,
I've heard it for real.
He's like,
I just,
I grabbed their pussies and I just take it.
Oh yeah.
You've been missing out.
It's really good.
Yeah.
You know,
and the best part is you're going to do what you want.
I grab women by the Pussy.
Yeah.
You just,
you just grab him by the opposing
dub.
That bitch go.
Let's see here.
Maybe gravel,
Blah there.
Plus.
Okay.
This one says it has graphic language.
Oh,
it's so great.
She's still,
I moved on her actually,
you know,
she was down in Palm Beach.
I moved on her NFL.
I'll admit it.
I did try and fuck her.
She was married to Sarah.
I know Nancy and I moved on her very heavily.
In fact,
I took her out furniture shopping.
She wanted to get some furniture.
I said,
I'll show you where they have some nice furniture.
I took her out furniture,
bitch.
I couldn't get there and she was married.
Then all of a sudden I see her.
She's now got the big phony tents and everything.
She's totally changed her looks.
She's your girl's hot as shit in the purple.
Hello?
Hello.
Hey,
wait.
You got to look at it when you get to have this up.
Oh,
that's pretty much.
It gets better.
It does stay with you and I will walk down.
I'm glad they publish it.
There's another one that's supposed to be one more piece on NBC.
Yeah,
that's a new one.
Just in case.
Just start kissing her
automatically attracted to beautiful.
I just started kissing them
and when you're a star,
they let you do it.
You can do anything.
Whatever you want,
grab them by the Pussy.
Ladies and gentlemen,
the future president of the United States.
I haven't heard it like that.
It's so much different to hear that then.
Um,
yeah,
it's better.
Yeah.
I hate censored clips.
It takes the gravity out of it.
When you hear a Douche bag being a douche bag,
it's so much better grab them by the Pussy.
Like you have to be a real savage to use that phrase.
Right.
Because I mean you guys do locker room talk.
I'm sure you and your in your bros.
When you guys broke down,
do you guys say things like you can just grab her by her pussy fucking grabbed
by the pussy?
No,
I would say cause I've heard a lot,
there's weird on on,
on Twitter there's a lot of like,
yeah,
that's how people,
I heard people saying like that's how people talk.
Like no,
not people.
Here's,
here's guy talk for guys I would
say is like,
well look at her tits.
Look like if you're,
if you're being crude it's usually like look at her,
right?
Like yeah look at that ass.
Yeah,
she's fucking hot,
you know.
But like that it's not usually like,
yeah,
you know what I do is I always go there and I grabbed their pussies.
That's crazy.
People would be like,
what?
What are you talking about?
It's a stranger.
It is a kind of a weirder idea.
That'd be like me,
me,
like I just,
I just grab him by the Cox.
Yeah.
Like wait,
what?
That's such a vulgar.
It's too much.
It's too,
it's almost,
it is kind of a violent idea.
Yeah.
It's aggressive.
It's weird,
man.
Yeah.
I,
it's really a bummer.
So apparently there's even more that NBC is withholding.
They're not,
oh,
releasing.
There's even more of him saying crazy stuff and there's petitions.
I just,
I just signed one to have it released to,
to pressure NBC to release him being even creepier.
Cause I really get a kick out of these.
I think they're super fun.
Super Funny.
They suspended Billy Bush.
I'm just seeing this right now.
Oh,
his career is over too,
right?
It's over.
Um,
well he's participating with the,
so it says,
uh,
Bush released an apology.
Gamin you know,
he was sitting there.
Yeah.
Basically being the sidekick,
which is just embarrassing because I think every guy at least has played that
role usually into,
in the scenario where you're hanging out with the more of an Alpha male.
Right.
So you're,
the Alpha male is saying stuff and you're like,
yeah,
fuck her.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
And it's just,
I think everybody,
I know myself,
I've played that role,
you know,
it kind of,
it happens naturally,
but to have it played back for you has to be just so he wanted it.
Oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I mean to be like,
you're the man man.
Like yeah.
Stick lucky that like Michael Jordan,
you're so cool.
Like that's basically what he was doing there.
Yeah.
Because what's he supposed to say is as Billy Bush supposed to be like,
you know what sir,
I don't think we should degrade women.
Yeah.
I Dunno what I mean.
It's,
I don't think that's appropriate.
Dot.
I don't know what they were at and wanting to dump the don,
he was definitely like cheerleading and uh,
you know,
he was doing the,
yeah.
Yeah.
Actually locker room talk is kind of what he did.
Like,
whoa.
Yeah,
look here.
She's hot.
They're saying it about some girl that's off camera there.
Right?
Like that's kind of,
yeah,
that's normal.
That's a normal locker.
So that's,
I mean that's,
I've heard guys say that a million times.
Yeah.
She's fucking hot.
Which is fine.
But the,
the best part is that hot chick comes to greet them as part of like the show.
I guess they're taping the apprentice.
Yeah.
And you see them.
It's Kinda,
it's kind of grody cause he's saying all that stuff.
And then,
and then him and Billy are like a what?
A,
why don't you give him a kiss?
Yeah.
Hug Him,
give him a hug,
give him a kiss.
Like they've just proved out on her.
Yeah.
And then they're kind of manipulating her and she's on camera,
so she's like,
uh Huh.
Okay.
Oh,
you're both Hanson.
You know,
it's kind of a Douchey,
douchey thing to force that on somebody.
No,
not really.
Are you?
Sorry,
I don't know.
I've never been the type that I guess goes for it like that.
The O two with checks like that on your style.
My style was always like,
if affection comes to me then you know what I mean?
Like you mean like a normal human being?
Someone shows interest,
you go for it.
Yeah.
Kind of like our,
I was never like
right.
Like a predator.
Yeah.
Well there are guys that are just sharks,
right?
They just go for it.
Yeah,
sure.
I mean,
I know so gross throughout life I've met guys whose whose style,
which just crazy,
but I can smell those douchebags and a mile away cause it's a thousand
compliments.
Right.
And then God,
girl,
Girl,
you got me,
girl,
you so key.
You got me going from across the boom girl.
Oh really?
How are you doing better now that I'm talking to you,
you're like,
oh my God.
Right.
So obvious.
Better.
Now that I'm talking to you,
it's usually,
you know,
the brothers would step to me really in the clubs.
Yeah.
Well,
this is what I'm in my twenties and early,
you know,
late teens,
twenties in the,
I now have been in nightclubs since I was 20.
Yeah,
what's crazy is he was 59 when he was talking like it was a younger immature
man.
That's what they were critiquing the uh,
Billy Bush fork is his,
his apology was saying I was younger and immature and he was 34,
not 19.
Yeah.
19 year old saying this stuff and I'd be like,
well dude,
they're retarded.
He'll learn.
Let's see.
Do you want to hear this ladies?
If they cut it up,
the remix.
Oh,
I love to,
yeah,
it's good.
It's good.
Then in the background Skyler's how boy Skyler,
that's officially over right.
Skylar.
Are we done with that name?
Uh,
yeah,
I think so.
It's tough.
Tough name.
See if there's any more.
I thought there was a couple other remixes.
Let's see.
The best is like making a video like she made and not realizing that people are
like,
yeah.
And then turn it into a hundred remixes of her crying and I liked this rap
music.
I could get into rap if it was like,
this is Vince staples,
man.
It's hilarious what she was doing.
Yeah.
Because of Niggas like me or she goes,
you know what I find really funny is when people are offended and then they go
and as a mom,
as if the,
those things have never existed in society and you have absolutely zero
responsibility to tell your kids like,
hey,
is entertainment.
You know,
like the thing of the children can't dare you.
Like wow,
your kid,
you know,
I think this is for people older than you.
It's not for you,
for you,
because of what?
A few years you'll be fucking and then you can listen to them.
Then you can fuck your boyfriend.
Tell all this cool music.
Yeah.
You know?
You know,
she was always nice to me.
She never called me a Nigga.
Oh for fuck.
Okay.
Set me up cigarette.
He set me up.
It was pretty good.
Hey,
guess what I'm doing today?
What I'm going on?
Not just [inaudible] NATO.
If you guys know he gone day,
I don't know when it will air.
So it might be airing today.
I don't know how it,
how the,
how it's structured.
Yeah.
I assume it might air today,
which is going to be too late,
but I'm sure it'll live on mine.
I'm doing,
uh,
not just competitor Nieto is so exciting.
It's,
that means you're going to be interviewed by a clown today.
Yeah.
And it's in Spanish,
right?
Yeah.
This is a,
so are you going to speak Spanish or how are we going to do this guy's Arad?
No,
just go and plant a neat though.
The night of plantings.
No,
it's,
it's like evenings with,
but the Nico,
that guy,
oh right there.
[inaudible] Nieto and he's like,
oh,
I'm so sneaky.
I am a clown,
but oh,
so do you get paid and Tacos to do this day?
But God,
you're terrible.
Oh,
plantings.
No,
no.
That's his name.
I love it.
No worries.
Yeah.
Got It.
I got it.
I can't wait.
Exert,
so I'm the,
I'm the lead guest and I get to do an interview and I get to play two games.
What are your,
do you know your games?
Yeah.
Can you tell me or,
I don't want to spoil it,
but I think Daca Lewis internal,
I think you see somebody has on a body suit with basically items hidden in them.
And I'm supposed to touch with a blind folded and then we're doing dominoes one,
not the game dominoes,
but with Domino's sticks,
you know,
like just actual dominoes set up.
Yep.
And they fall over and then if I get,
if they get something wrong,
they pour cold water down my pants.
No,
really,
you have to bring a change of clothes.
That's awesome.
Yeah.
Oh my God,
we have to see this.
Yeah.
And see this I,
it will be online with you today.
It'll be online,
man.
I'm so jealous because he could put in a good word for me in plants.
Anytime you want to be on a kind of,
yeah,
yeah.
I'm sure this is like the only show worth doing.
Fuck the tonight show.
[inaudible] this is where it's at.
Yup.
This is it,
man.
I haven't seen you this excited by the way.
Like you've done Conan and you're like,
yeah,
I'm doing Conan tonight and then this one you've been,
you got your hair done.
I bought a new jacket.
Replaced the lost jacket.
You did.
It's really good.
The one that you bought.
Yeah.
I have not seen you this excited to do television ever because I am really,
I'm just really excited for it.
I'm stoked man.
This is in the great tradition of Latin television.
Yeah.
Of Sabado.
He Gone Day,
which is one of my favorites that we watched in Florida when you were sick once,
when we were on vacation.
We want to
do this shit's Rad.
Look how much fun they have on this show.
Oh Man.
These guys have a good time.
Yeah,
man.
Not like white people.
White people never have fun.
I bet it's funny.
One plot that Nieto is like off off camera and mad about something.
Right.
And he's demanding like where the fuck is my water?
And then,
and he's in his clown thing and the PA has to be like,
how'd he say it in Spanish?
What were the fuck is my water [inaudible]
beat shower.
Pinch Jajuan say I have to take a chair.
I love that concept of mine.
Oh,
I like that.
Yeah.
Speaking of water,
um,
I don't know if you noticed my new container that I'm drinking out of it.
It's a,
I got this in Dallas from a couple of Mommy's,
Katie and Trevor.
Thank you.
Uh,
you can't see it,
but it's um,
it says main mommy water champion and it's,
what's the word?
Um,
where they engrave it.
It's engraved on here,
so thank you Katie and Trevor.
Look stupid.
I,
I'm going to cherish this.
I'm going to hand this down to my children,
my children's children.
Everybody will know that I am the true water.
Right
Ellis.
Carl's Jr.
You'll have to decide who gets to actually keep it.
Right.
Ruth's Chris's Tom's risk.
Chris Tom's here.
Mm.
Yep.
Anyways,
I really appreciate this guys.
I had a great time and Dallas and in Houston and in Portland and to come on Ya.
Yeah.
It's just nice that the fans really know who leads through other pussy.
So Gray Water Jambi in it.
That's so great.
Can we always play that?
You can wait til if he is president.
You can do anything.
Whatever you want,
grab them by the Pussy.
She's as Christ did.
So wait,
you have to touch,
is it a man or a woman in a body suit and then guests the objects?
Uh,
well I saw what they did
on a,
so they sent me a video of it and what they did was they had a girl and then
they,
they uh,
blindfolded the guys and the girl walks away and a guy walked off.
Larry is so I'm pretty sure that'll happen to me.
So sexual,
Latin culture.
So that's what they do.
So the guys like,
oh how can we,
I just have sexual you Latins I dunno.
It's all,
I think it's all come.
Um,
you know,
well who are we talking about that ran out of com watching TV last night and
you're like,
oh he's a man cause he woke when,
where's the com?
Yeah,
cause he knows he looks so old nowadays.
You really?
Yeah.
Well we were both noting that bill looks so,
you know,
he's aged,
he is a in dog years.
He's very old.
Yeah.
And you said it's because he's out of comm?
I think so.
We think Monica sucked it all out.
No,
I don't think Monica did.
I think it's just,
you know,
with the years it's just gone.
The Km,
the km fades.
Yeah.
He's really like more frail looking now.
Not that old.
Right.
I don't know how old he is.
I think it up.
I think it's more startling because we're used to the younger spry bill.
He's 70.
He's my dad's age.
That's not that old.
Come on.
It's not,
it's not,
he looks very sunken.
Like his face looks real.
Yeah.
I know.
He lost weight.
I mean he,
he lost a bunch of weight after,
you know,
leaving office.
Oh yeah,
no,
he,
you know,
I think he changed.
I know you had hard thing and he has been sick.
Yeah.
But I think,
uh,
well I can't do a lot of fucking,
and he's an outcome is that outcome.
So I think you're on the right path there.
[inaudible] you think I'm on the right path?
Yeah.
Uh,
yeah.
Yeah.
We've been doing that a lot in front of our son Ellis Belching and it's fun to
bourbon out of the kid.
Just go like,
he just looks at you like,
what was that?
Is that a word?
Yeah.
We're teaching him all the fundamentals of a good line by the pussy.
I'm my God can you didn't handle it that that's the future president possibly.
It's so retarded.
Ah,
President Reagan's slogan.
Yeah.
America.
America by the poster.
Yeah.
Make America grab it by the Pussy.
Yes.
That's the Stutz dumbest slogan.
Grab America by the Pussy.
I think the funny thing will be,
um,
because there was also this a apprentice producer,
those tweeting is like,
I was a producer on seasons one and two.
He's like,
man,
there's a lot crazier stuff that I think the,
I think that's what we're trying to get released.
Right,
right.
But my thing is he's going to have like,
that's going to be such an embarrassment,
you know,
I kept him.
If it's way crazier than that,
why Chrisy yeah.
Cause he's probably,
he's a bragger type,
you know?
Yes.
I know that he likes to brag about chicks because they,
it's,
it's long been his,
you know,
his thing.
So he'll probably have a lot of like,
you see that girl over there,
she's fucked her in the bathroom.
Yeah.
Shit like that,
you know.
Wow.
What did she uh,
she say it was okay.
I don't give a shit.
Just stuck it in her mouth.
How do we get here as a society?
You know,
I'm,
I'm so bummed that we don't have cable right now just because I wanted to watch
Fox News and I'm curious to see how they are spinning this into a positive
light.
Well
yeah,
it did he say grabbed by the Posey or did he mean it that way?
I don't know.
Kind of turns you on a little.
Definitely does this.
I also,
oh no movable to know which can be very sexy for role playing.
For instance,
you might have fantasies of having sex with an athlete,
like the hockey player.
Sometimes hockey
players will lose a tooth when you get faced with the puck.
So I can give you a chance to live out your fantasies and have sex with multiple
men.
Yeah,
I'll show you.
No,
no,
no.
She now I looked like a tough guy.
Like,
like a hot red nick or a hockey player and I can put on wigs.
I have like six different wigs and we can role play and have cool fantasies.
The fantasy.
Yeah,
kind of.
I uh,
I kind of respect that,
you know,
you know what I,
I hate that I can hear how dry his mouth is.
All that stuff.
Yeah.
That's the problem.
That's one of the problems.
I feel like I'm,
one of the cool things is I think he's making a video just appealing to the
public is what it feels like.
Now we're in the general,
not the Vegan.
Well,
I'm sure.
No,
I'm sure it's,
it's for Vegans,
but I just liked that he is,
um,
he's just making a video promoting why he's a sexual conquest in other words.
Uh Huh.
Hey look,
another thing is great about me.
And he spun the,
the no tooth and little positive,
you know,
Sean sackers here.
Yeah.
That's important.
That you can turn a negative into a positive and in his case,
make it sexually.
Yes.
A pls convict.
Shine.
That's who that is.
Oh,
so now it's that.
I'm
don't have this got a little bit of food on here.
I'm going to throw up.
Oh,
he's looking at it.
You know,
I know.
Oh.
Oh
he is.
So he is licking his tooth.
He is licking his fucking tooth.
I'm going to throw up.
Oh,
that really affected me and icontact.
pretend that I'm licking your balls are your penis.
What?
Dude?
That was really gnarly.
That was nor why did you do that?
It's not hot at all,
bro.
That is so fucking gnarly,
man.
I respect that.
You're trying to get puss puss,
but God damn it.
Yes.
Wait,
gotta be something.
Screw this.
Makes my tongue feel so haslup hitting the table.
I can't control it.
I can't.
Would you turn it off in the throw up?
I love,
I'm going to be conferred.
Shyness.
If I'm out and I'm 10
oh,
I feel like I feel really sick.
He was licking food that was on his too.
Why?
But why?
That's not even hot.
That's not even in the world of Utah.
Think about,
of course it's hot lick.
Your,
your
prosthetic candidate.
I'm licking your balls are your penis or your penis or whoever.
Whoever's around.
I'm licking.
That was rough man.
Yeah,
it doesn't,
it doesn't.
I'm trying to sit up properly.
Have you noticed,
I wish you'd commend in,
Oh,
uh,
by the way,
budget people listened to the Burke cast with bill burr and myself and they're
like Tom's breathing heavily to the mic.
We were smoking cigars,
cigars,
right.
You dicks also catch us on the last episode of the Jay are we did it last week
if you guys haven't already.
Yeah.
A scene that heard it.
Whatever.
Joseph Rogan's.
Yes.
And I got a fanny pack from him and I was opposed to it for years and I really,
really,
really fight for it.
Well,
cause when I take baby jeans out in public,
you've got a diaper bag,
a baby I don't have,
where do I put my stupid purse?
Yeah.
So I was cramming my pockets full of my phone,
my money and women's clothing.
There's no pockets.
Yeah.
So I was forced kind of in a way to use it.
And I,
I'm a huge fan.
I'm a huge advocate now have a fanny pack.
I'm really,
it's for real.
Mom's only really surprised me.
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
It really surprised me.
That was just so it grows really.
It had many layers and tiers to it.
Um,
shit a lot the other day,
remember,
you know what was actually going to bring up was that,
uh,
at my show and Ontario thank you to everybody that came to the Ontario Improv.
Yeah.
Last Thursday.
Really Fun to shows.
Second show,
somebody punched another dude in the face,
in the line happening to our shows.
And I,
I tried to,
I didn't bring it up during the show cause I've learned that on a late night.
If that already happened,
let it go,
let it go.
Uh,
I kind of wanted to bring it up later in the show,
but I honestly,
I forgot.
But what I was told,
what happened was a guy was smoking in line and another guy goes,
hey man,
my girl has asthma.
Do you mind going over there to smoke?
And the guy
turn around and punched him.
Wow.
And that was a late show Friday,
Thursday,
Thursday.
Wow.
Alcohol tends to play a role in,
and that I,
that was a verified story from multiple accounts.
I don't know if that's really how it went down,
but that's what people are saying.
I thought that was pretty,
there's someone got punched out in my showroom in Tacoma.
It's come on your comedy club.
I don't know if I talked about on this show,
but yeah,
a punched out.
What is happening to the world?
What is going on guys?
Don't punched at our shows.
Could,
you know,
punching people the fuck.
I like that the guy was just asked.
Right.
Hey Man,
do you,
can you go over there?
Fuck you man.
Yeah.
That's some prisons shit.
You know,
could be more.
Yeah,
it's really neat.
Yeah.
Um,
I had really good time in Dallas and Poussin and Seattle.
Uh,
and uh,
Portland.
Yeah.
It's really fun.
Can I,
can I,
I'm going to read you an exchange I had with someone that worked at the club in
Dallas.
Can I,
can I read this?
Yeah,
sure.
You know when you come across people
who give a shit so little the air like wow.
I,
I kind of almost,
um,
admire your level of not giving a fuck.
Of course.
Let see if I can find it.
You know,
I switched phones.
Oh shoot.
You know what?
I think it's gone.
Really.
I was using the phone.
I had no phone this last week.
Whatever you want to grab 'em by the pussy like that and like just not Karen,
like not caring.
I,
I'll,
I'll paraphrase.
So I fucked up my phone and I didn't have a Sim card in it.
And um,
so I had no way of making phone calls as I was traveling through Dallas and
Houston.
And for me that's annoying.
There's no public phones anymore.
Do you know that?
Like in the airport they'd ripped out all the public phones,
so you can't even really make a public phone call.
So I text this person employee in Dallas.
I was like,
Hey,
I can only communicate if I'm on wireless.
I don't have a phone.
Can you just meet me in,
in baggage claim?
And then we can go to the hotel,
which is normal and I think not an odd request.
And he writes this?
Yeah,
he writes back,
okay.
And then a few minutes later he goes,
you know,
I really,
I don't want to pay to park.
Can you?
Can you just stand outside?
And then I'll just drive round.
And I was like,
I'm all pay for parking.
Just come in,
you know?
And I'm like,
really?
You're that fucking lazy as a human being like,
motherfucker,
you can't park and walk 20 steps.
There's a lot of really lazy people,
right?
To just meet the headliner of one night.
I'm just there for one night.
I don't know anybody in Dallas.
Like I don't have a,
I'm a grown woman.
Like do
you have the arrangement?
Unbelievable.
Like,
Hey,
I'm here.
I'm at baggage claim.
I should be there in 20 minutes.
You know that I'm flying across the kind of cross.
I flew across the country today for you.
And then you go and then they're like,
hey,
it's been like 25 30 minutes standing there like a doggy in here.
I was here on time.
Why aren't you fucking here on time?
It's not a huge request.
So then this person,
um,
when they shut up,
I was like,
he was,
he gave me grief for it.
He was like,
whoa.
Normally,
uh,
just drive around a bunch and the person stands out there.
I'm like,
I didn't,
I'm sorry.
I didn't want to do that.
And then the car ride was silence and then the car ride to the airport the next
morning was total Sila.
He wouldn't even talk to me.
I think so.
Cause I was a little like uppity.
I think that was a huge request for this person.
Never to park and walk in and meet the headliner of the club for one night.
It was so,
it was so,
uh,
it really made me sad.
And then the next day that's when I listened to top 40 music.
He was listening and full blast.
And the commercials too would listen through the commercials.
Right.
Which to me is totally retarded.
If you're listening to radio commercials,
full volume,
and you're like,
I don't care,
whatever,
whatever goes in my ear holes mountain,
I don't care.
Yeah,
you're fucking retarded.
Yeah.
So anyway,
that was right.
Am Am I overreacting here?
I feel like it's an emotional response.
Like it's,
it's what happens when you go like,
you know,
I do this pretty seriously and professionally about things.
Yeah.
And then when I feel like you slag off,
it's a,
it's upsetting.
You know,
when you don't want to put in effort to do something,
it's like I'm putting an effort.
Yeah.
I'll put an effort,
you know,
to get here.
I'm going to do press.
I need you to,
I'm going to do the shirt.
Yeah.
And then you're like,
whatever.
And then he made me,
he then he let me pay for the parking,
but class $4 slash took my four fucking dollars.
I'm like,
wow,
bro,
you gotta be kidding me.
Yeah.
But Dallas was great.
Everybody's great.
Oh,
our fans are amazed.
I mean,
they're all,
they're always fantastic.
They made up for it,
but I was like,
what the fuck?
Unreal.
You don't give a shit about anything,
Huh?
You know when people just don't give a fuck about their lives?
Like,
how do you not give a fuck about your life?
That I'm like,
I can tell if you don't care about this,
you don't care about a lot of stuff,
man.
I agree.
Shit,
it's upsetting.
It's upsetting.
How?
Just how it's cheap and shitty.
Some some,
it can be,
you know,
there's some good clubs out there,
there's good owners that run it well,
that care,
that want to treat you well and it's not luxury stuff.
It's just like,
you know,
care,
you know the care I don't demand.
There's like just such bullshit on the other and then bring me a limousine or I
demand,
you know,
Fiji water and my green room.
I'll tell you something like,
I've think I've said it before,
but it's just so,
it makes you feel like shit when,
when they'll send someone with a filthy car to pick you up.
It really upsets me.
We're like a car comes in,
there's trash,
trash,
and then they have to move the trash off.
You're like,
am I supposed to sit in here?
Come on.
Like,
this is how you treat the person.
Do what?
I mean it makes me feel like really disrespected.
It should cause it is.
You wouldn't pick up your friend in a,
in a thick nylon like a work person.
It's a work relationship.
That's the thing.
If you worked in an office and you're asked to pick up an executive,
you show up in a trashy,
I know like food.
We'll just shows like it's usually from the top on down when it's like,
you know,
it's like the,
that's how they run the club.
Yeah.
They don't care.
God Damn.
It had been in and it had been a minute since I had experienced,
I don't give a fuck like that where I was like,
all right dude.
It's pretty bad.
Crazy.
Pretty bad.
Anyways,
that was my drama.
Yeah,
that was dollars.
Yeah.
I think I've had a pretty good run lately with that kind of stuff.
You know?
Pretty good.
I've had some nice wait,
so real nice.
Wait
after four hour flights where you're like,
I just want,
I only have two hours to rest in the hotel and they're like,
just make it another half hour.
Yeah,
I'm almost there.
Yeah.
I've been
picked up and you get have the traffic.
No,
it's,
no it isn't.
Or maybe it is.
And maybe you should've thought of that before you.
Um,
I've shown up,
I've flown across the country like fully east coast,
showed up at like 10:00 PM at night and the next morning have to do 5:00 AM
press.
They've been late or they haven't been at the airport and then my hotel wasn't
booked and we had to frantically search for another,
oh my God.
You're like,
really bro,
this comedy game man,
this comedy game.
But Hey,
you want to hear everyone else was amazing.
So
right.
[inaudible]
Neil Warnock manager,
football manager.
Well,
we won't tell you what we can do more than to play it in their
fucking lead.
Getting pissed.
Most passive.
Wow.
Love it.
I like the way he looks crazy,
so understand that.
I love that.
That's a wholly British.
Yeah,
I like that one.
You never hear that.
I liked that a lot.
I do too.
Okay.
No,
I like the long socks to mummy.
I'm wearing my lungs up.
Did you play soccer?
Yes.
Uh,
third grade.
Yeah.
That was it.
Americans don't play it past third grade Gen ed now it's getting way more
popular here.
The FIFO,
the next generation.
Our son's generation when they're older,
I think we're going to have more worldclass soccer players and then we're going
to stop circumcising everybody.
I hope not,
but I think that soccer is going to see an explosion because yeah,
because you're seeing there's more public interest in international games.
Um,
it's becoming,
it's definitely undeniably coming more popular.
So then when that happens,
more great athletes that would have played,
you know,
football or baseball or something.
You're to see more of them go to soccer and I think you'll see more American
soccer stars in the next 10,
20 years.
It's about Tom.
Yeah.
I mean we have some good ones,
but I think it's going to get even better.
That's going to get even better.
What's cool.
Yeah,
me too.
I like it.
I like soccer.
I do.
I like watching top level stuff.
You know,
I don't have an interest in watching like a fucking high school game here,
but when they,
when they have,
you know,
the really premier league stuff and the World Cup stuff.
I like watching that stuff.
Yeah,
it's good.
It's exciting.
It is.
Oh Geez.
How many times have we had,
I know.
We don't want you to know.
We want us to fucking stop it.
Yeah.
I liked going to cut.
Really loses it though.
Exasperated and he just fucking grabbing his hair.
It doesn't know what to do anymore.
That's the sign of real passion mixed with real anger.
Yeah.
Yes,
I agree.
I will be like that.
Now what part of the UK is this man from master of accents?
Where do you identify?
Oh yeah.
This is clear as this is so southern,
not even a das.
It's probably from mercy
right now we got 45 minutes.
I'm not bothered by fucking unconcerned.
Yeah,
I'm at about now.
Neil Warren upside out there.
Fucking 2000 finds out real goal and they will panic now.
Everybody calls you trade a backpack.
Don't be stopped.
This shit.
Now let's go out and get the fucking,
don't be soft as shit.
Yeah.
I think it's a giraffe arc or dark park.
Probably Hubris.
Harrisburg or Durham.
Third fired.
Yeah.
It's killing me.
This shit.
Um,
I like it.
Speaking of International.
Yeah.
Want to see some cool.
You happy with Rob Bark at you?
You Go,
you have it with rob live.
Bart Bruce Lowry.
And you are and dot.
Then Tom.
Oh my God.
That was amazing.
Oh,
Holy Shit.
That was the coolest thing we've ever gotten.
I know.
My Gosh.
I am so regretful that it doesn't say in my,
I have a clip bank here.
Oh,
who actually did this?
Thank you so much.
Couple things.
Nice bird.
Crisler is so enormous and it keeps getting bigger.
Yeah.
And he is indeed fatter than time.
And I'm glad that it's something we're seeing the world,
the world.
Oh,
Stan,
you know,
it's really great.
And I liked the word teaching the next generation.
Yeah.
About how fat bird is too.
And I love that.
These little,
wow,
that was cute.
So cute.
Can we adopt like 10 of them?
Oh,
Bart's Bruce Lowry.
You are
God then God,
that's amazing.
I love it.
And in India too,
you know what I mean?
I'm just going to text best file.
Yeah.
Nice to see this.
Hey Buddy.
You know what,
probably not make them so fad is if he spent some time in India.
Just ate something new.
It's so funny.
The street bart has a,
a new special coming out.
Yeah,
it's coming out in November.
He's shirtless.
Oh No,
no bad choice.
So like even as the,
the bird is fat thing,
Tom is fat kind of died down when that,
when those like Promo Start Airing and oh my God and the stills of it,
you have to promote it are going to be out.
He's going to get hammered so hard.
It's going to be really,
really great.
By the way,
I'm imagining like a tag.
Last show,
there is a new shirt.
It is the uh,
what is it?
It's called Dj.
Dad Mouth.
Dj Diamond has a new shirt.
Um,
I wanted to see if I have the uh,
the thing to show you.
I don't see it here.
Maybe I have another email,
but in the meantime I actually did the weather a few weeks ago.
I played like a super clip of me doing,
you know,
regular new stuff.
I've never done the weather before.
And then let me do the weather as Dj Dad Mountain.
Oh Nice.
Let's see.
I wanted to show you that.
See if I can play there.
Hey everybody.
Welcome back Cwi.
We'll live morning show.
I'm James Peterson back on my side here in front of the weather wall with duct
tape.
Also known as Mr Segura.
What's that man?
We wanted to come and he wanted to come in front of the chrome.
Well,
he's ever stood in front of a green wall.
So if you folks at home don't know.
This is called the Chroma Key,
Aka green screen,
green screen.
I'm going to let,
we'll let him do the weather.
I'm going to step out of here.
He's got to tell you about the rainfall.
Let's talk about rain real quick.
Man over here.
Cedar rapids here,
man,
you got a little over and it says nothing.
Look at Spencer Spencer.
Man,
y'all are wet mess.
So easy.
What does this deck,
Decorah,
Dick.
Cora.
Cora,
they're not having no rain or that you just felt lazy.
You didn't put like putting into the total.
There's Waterloo is other places other than I got duct tape for decor.
I'm not going to put it on the wall,
but here I would cover this up that cause you guys disrespected the Cora and you
also disrespected Davenport.
Yeah.
And let's see what else we got.
We're all there.
We're going to,
we're still the skycam.
Oh Sky Cam.
Oh look at this.
We'd like to thank our sponsors at Orin homes.
If you're looking for a house and you have money contact or in home and they'll
help you get it.
And if something breaks we'll put duct tape on is currently 63 here and as y and
the conditions are fake.
I even got in one of our dumb pronounciation.
Yeah,
somewhat.
Somewhat going.
Watch this.
Watch this little trick.
This fool shit
sweating.
It's not a health matters.
93% humidity.
It is muggy outside.
The winds are coming out to west.
South West.
Yeah.
Around six miles an hour.
If you don't have duct tape,
make sure you pick some up today.
It solves so many issues.
The core of not there on this one either.
They're obviously having technical issues.
So that's a technical problem.
The technical,
it is a good idea to bring out the duck.
Yes,
you could.
You could duck tape over them and we'll just get back to that set of blue
gaffers tape.
Here's your future tracker.
This tracker,
you've got to do the,
I'm gonna put,
I'm a let you buddy.
Yeah,
it's just a wall of water there.
And then Minneapolis is snowing very hard right now.
And also in Kansas City there's a lot of snow in fire
trackers,
letting you know that there's some rain in other things,
uh,
or in homes.
Doesn't sponsor this segment.
Anything else?
All right.
No,
we're going to walk back over here.
Dot.
Duck tape.
You Go.
Very good work,
Tommy.
Thanks.
Maybe I'm real proud of you.
I'm here is the,
uh,
the new shirt man.
Oh,
it looks good.
Yeah.
So it's a Dj dad mouth.
Love it.
I'm a listener.
Drew this.
Got Your Mom's house on the hat.
It's got good.
The goal.
Yeah.
It's pretty great.
Really good.
Let me see if I,
uh,
if I can pull up his,
I think I have his info,
his name,
just so I can give him the proper credit because he did a great job.
His name is Collins.
Yeah,
the chopper man on Instagram.
The chopper man.
Chapa.
Chapa diocese.
Yeah.
Thank you very much for doing that.
And thank you to everybody that did order the DJ dad mouse shirt.
Please order one.
Um,
it looks good.
I like it sounds kind of old school,
white and black.
Like we don't do a lot of white,
It's good.
Yeah,
it looks good.
It looks good with that design though.
Yeah.
Do it that way.
That's Rad.
So thank you.
Very nice.
Now unbelievably jeans.
Yeah.
You got a phone call.
It never ends.
So I have my phone in my hand and I was just walking into a building and the
phone rang and it was like the good fortune of,
I was like,
okay.
I immediately was like,
Oh,
don't touch the phone.
I don't want to mess this up.
And then I texted you and I'm like,
I got it.
The Persian ladies back.
I haven't heard it yet.
She just called me on Friday.
Here it is.
I haven't heard of
needs it a bit of a bitch fucking ticket to get quitting,
but Lango would clinic will not know.
I thought it was going to save him money cause let me do one more.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] to do more than you going to be
seen by he my lesson.
I couldn't sleep
anyway.
I know you have your own things.
We all have their own,
you know,
I still have,
I
talked to somebody.
It's a lot going on.
So long message and is clearly another woman.
Someone else upset about fucking this bitch.
Fuck her.
And it's better fucking money.
Money.
Yeah.
So there's an a whore.
I think she called her a whore too.
There's some word that we learned that was bad,
but she's um,
wow.
Really,
really fired.
Here's the beginning of
not in an accident.
She chatted a
little bit of a big ticket to get with him for nine or
10 to save her money.
Cause I mean
saving money,
nobody's trying to screw her over.
I love this dude.
Never,
but here's the thing,
doesn't she sometimes actually see Salamay right.
And be like,
Hey did you get my message?
Or like,
or that thing I told you about.
And then Solomon is like,
no,
I never get your calls.
Never.
Yeah,
I never do.
So dude,
I'm so stoked she's back though because I feel like I was worried that there was
a lull in our relationship and now she's back again.
So this is amaze.
We need somebody who speaks Farsi to come in here maybe.
And do you think we should call her one day and talk to her?
I'd be like,
what's your,
you know what I mean?
Like to wrap this up or I just feel like we need,
we need closure on this.
Call her cause you speak some English,
right?
We just car one day and be like,
I know you've
been looking for Salamay.
She's like,
what?
How the fuck do you know shit.
We have to piece together all the translations first.
Kind of be like,
look,
I just want to tell you we have plastic bags on the tree.
Squirrels,
Tony,
you that we know about this bitch fucking you over for money and we want to
help.
Right.
We want to help you.
She's like,
fuck you.
Yeah.
Where does Solomon work?
Salah Mae's.
Okay.
She's in the basement.
She's tied up.
You can have her back but first we want the password.
Yeah.
Her and I've been getting,
I still get calls for Shanaze.
There's a lot of uh,
nursing opportunities in Florida that she's been missing out on for the last
year since I've had this phone number.
Yeah.
Um,
but then atus I stopped getting calls for,
for adas cause he left Rehab early and they're looking for him.
But it kind of makes me want to get a new number just to see if there's any
exciting things that'll happen for my phone number,
if you're lucky.
I mean,
I feel like this number,
it's a real blessing in the skies and it,
yeah.
There's like once a lifetime
you give it out.
Yeah.
No,
that happened at that.
Joe Did that on accident one time.
He did.
He tried to direct message.
Somebody has number and he tweeted shit.
Oh Shit.
Yeah.
His phone cut down like it was Ron.
Ron.
Like I couldn't handle the volume up.
Oh Shit.
Yeah,
that'd be terrible.
Oh my God.
Yes.
What is this?
You sent me 22 seconds.
Is this good?
What is this?
Oh,
it's a,
it's a fart.
Fart.
Yeah.
Tag a friend and tell them.
Good
morning.
I just figured you like it.
Oh,
good morning.
Mores sexy boy.
I just liked her,
uh,
giving money.
I liked that she did it in a sexy way,
right?
Yeah.
She can still maintain her sex appeal.
A good money.
Oh,
oh,
oh
the nosy Rosie.
No,
no.
Can I,
did you see nosy Rosie?
Oh,
can you,
I,
if it's too hard to pull up.
Oh,
is that in your mind?
Okay.
I was,
um,
I loved,
I,
there's a few things Instagram knows I like,
I like golf stuff and then I like tiny dogs,
so I get a lot of the,
you know,
they recommend people's feeds to you.
And I found one under tiny dogs that really,
really major struck my heart.
Nosy.
Rosie,
what are you doing?
A nosy Rosie.
It's the weekend changing.
What's your plan?
I will out and get drunk
and I got to go do some techno and desi.
Hmm.
Makes your nor Ruthie.
You okay.
Okay.
Do you want to go to parties and Jean,
I'm going to go clubbing.
No,
you want to wear some high heels and go to club
Zeros anyway,
I think he wants to put on some high heels and go to the club and the roofing.
Uh,
so he does,
I couldn't find nosy Rosie,
but remind me of that old club we had.
Yes.
I think it's him.
A paper stuck in butter on now.
It's not him,
but it definitely sounds like it can be stuck.
A button.
Oh No.
Oh,
his paper is talking about,
oh no.
Oh No.
Bye guys.
Great.
Just crazy.
Okay.
There's dogs too.
Got Stuck
and they're humping and oh my God,
cleanness got stuck in another dog.
Oh my God.
Oh.
I think he's not.
Hey Man.
Good luck.
Fucking night of Carla.
Carla,
all day now I think labeled.
That's a Singaporean accent because she mentions or is it says he's in Singapore
because I of course immediately went to every post this guy has ever done.
Oh,
but people,
uh,
of that,
of,
of this here.
Yeah.
Oh No.
They gave us a bunch of feedback.
Oh,
where?
Where was that?
He was,
I can't remember now.
I think Cambodian or something.
And they were saying that that's what you're the master of accents.
I tell me
his paper is stuck in motto.
No.
Yeah,
Cambodian.
Yeah.
What about the change in owner?
This,
this Guy Dude?
Yeah.
What they'll go clubbing get.
Don't get roofie.
Oh No.
Nosy Rosie.
He's Super Gay.
So great.
Oh No.
Oh No,
no,
no.
The Rosie Guy,
that was your nosy Rosie.
Rosie.
Rosie,
and let the good that they did to techno music for about techno music.
Grab 'em by the Pussy,
wants to get his pussy grab.
Oh,
uh,
new accident.
You like it?
No.
Um,
we have a fan question.
They me to read it to you.
Any common those balls.
Oh,
okay.
A deer's Mommy's.
My girlfriend and I are having quite the debate about how one enters the shower.
Go ahead.
I like a civilized,
educated and well hydrated.
Mommy prefer to pull the shower curtain door towards the front of the shower.
I don't understand her the back.
Oh,
got God.
And approach the water like someone
who doesn't have daddy issues.
My cave dwelling counterpart,
whoever chooses to pull the curtain door back and enter directly into the water.
It's as if she's so hydrated.
The thought of being immediately boiled to death or frozen solid doesn't pass
into her mind as the water temperature adjusts.
I'm sorry.
It says if she's so dehydrated I'm willing to bet she even likes the vomit
flavored lemon lime Gatorade.
I'd greatly appreciate any input from the true water champion Tommy.
And if the main mommy's Tina lips aren't so chapped,
the speaking would split them.
I'd enjoy her input as well.
Yours truly scooter macgyver,
scooter.
Great question.
And you are dating a psychopath.
You absolutely are to approach shower temperature,
water.
That way you walk in,
you gauge the room,
the scenario,
you know where your exits are at.
Okay.
And then you,
you can even feel sometimes just by standing you don't have to touch water.
You can feel the,
the temperature it's putting off,
make some adjustments may put a hand or an Armin and then you slowly,
you kind of walk into it as you are finding the temperature.
You're like,
you don't just walk in like a crazy person.
I totally disagree.
Well yeah,
but you don't know.
You're talking about,
I've always entered when we had sliding doors in and Redondo jeans.
Yeah,
I would always enter.
And the front,
you mean you're telling me you would enter in the back if there's a front and a
back shower like that?
I would walk in to the back and walk up to it.
Yeah,
never.
I would always go and think about how stupid it is.
I'd always go in and then they go,
oh fuck,
fuck.
Move my body around the,
I mean the only way that I would do it.
The other,
the way you're talking about,
the only way I do it like that would be if I was like testing the water to find
my right temperature,
but if it's one of those return on it's running,
no.
I would walk in and gauge it like that's how I didn't hotels.
I'm like,
all right.
I know I've been doing it stupid my whole life.
I guess when you changed now we give it for 40 years of my life or whatever.
I've been doing it dumb and I've been just burning myself like walking around
the stream to her.
She never too late.
Never too late to change.
Yeah,
it is right.
I've been doing it dumb.
Yeah.
It's like when you discovered the defy Yay Fi's yogurt that you can put the,
the sweet part.
If you bend it over us over into the yogurt.
I was doing it.
It'd be like going to a batting cage and being like,
I want to see one come out.
Just let it,
fuck.
You'd watch one,
you know like,
let me see how this thing comes out real quick.
Yeah.
God,
I've been an idiot for a long time on now.
Another thing you're being pointed out about you is another email.
Go ahead.
Called Tina the serial killer.
Something's been bothering me all week.
Tina talks about how Tommy,
the main money is mentally unstable and probably going to kill her and her sleep
as we found out.
Tina enjoys watching men get brutally kicked in the balls.
She laughs real hard at it.
She even openly admit she'd do that type of porn herself.
That's some serial killer level shit.
It's her torturing of animals.
Say what you want about Tom.
Finding that funny video of the Asian getting run over by a car.
Funny,
but Tommy is isn't offering to drive the car.
Tommy,
I'm worried about your safety and your wellbeing is watch your back buttons.
Carl.
Thanks Carl.
And actually I've been thinking the same thing and I've actually purchased a
room divider I'm going to use at night to make sure that I sleep peacefully and
safely and that I don't have.
You had to worry about because I do think you really get excited by that.
It's physical harm being inflicted by a woman.
You really get off.
Well,
listen,
you're forgetting one important aspect of that is that the guy is asking for
that thing.
Yeah.
Okay.
So it's,
she's not just doing it and he wants that and you're just meeting somebody very
sick needs.
So what's wrong with that?
What's more beautiful than she went to bed with speed?
It's a blanket.
It's a beautiful thing.
You think that's a beautiful thing?
More beautiful than a woman kicking a man in the balls when he desperately wants
that to happen.
I can think of a few things.
Um,
something else.
Uh,
hold on.
Let's see if that,
does that work?
Yes.
Um,
something I want to point out to you last week on the show when you submit your
dirty ash tray,
please.
I think it's empty.
It's not all down,
but you know,
we got to be so nasty time.
Wake up nasty all the time.
Last time on the show,
God that you made a handshake agreement that you would eat.
Oh,
dog food.
Well,
the reason you want it to,
if you had a great hypothesis,
you wondered aloud.
You said if a person eats a bunch of dog food,
well their shit smell like dog shit.
I didn't come up with that thought that was a listener.
Okay,
email.
It was not mine.
I don't remember that.
So I'm glad you pointed that out.
Not your thought.
So what I want to know is,
mmm,
yeah,
I want to do it.
I don't want to,
you don't have to do it if you don't want to know.
Well,
I want to know if it's true.
I think that's a great experiment to try.
So what I have for you,
a bottle or a can of small and toy breed dog food.
Are you serious?
Well,
let's see if it has.
First of all,
you said you would take a bike.
You said you would take a bite.
So what
about,
here's the thing,
we need to find out.
Here's a bit for you.
It's a big deal.
I got it from your sons that he would lend it to you.
What we need to find out though is if you eat this whole camp,
we said,
okay,
let's see how it affects your,
your dumps and your smells.
Are we being serious?
You really want me to do this?
You gave a solid handshake that you would try a bike,
but we said that you buy me this ring that I had been eyeballing.
I will buy you a ring.
It's a hundred dollar ring and it's not that crazy.
But yeah,
for sure.
How much,
what's a bite?
I mean,
just if you're,
I think you should just try it.
How can you smell it?
Try smiling.
I've fed him this shit this morning.
It actually,
well,
here's the thing.
It's not bad.
Now that you read all these new agey kind of books and things,
why don't you just picture that?
It's something else.
Close your eyes.
Mm.
It's,
it's waffles with whipped cream.
Delicious thing is,
let's see what's in this.
Is that,
so I feed bitsy and fefe every morning obviously,
and Betsey's food smells like just a dirty feet and trash.
It's kibble.
It's disgusting.
But every time I opened fiefs food,
I'm like,
this isn't terrible.
It's you're holding right now.
And it's not,
it's,
it's grody.
Like I know that the shit in it,
it's gross with the gravy.
Kindness.
It's not bad.
Smell it.
The gravy is not that.
Just take away.
No,
I'm serious.
Just smell it.
You don't have to eat it.
It's not bad.
It's not terrible.
Okay,
so let's see.
This is sad.
This is Hill's science diet and we put Fif on the special wet food cause he had
crystal in his urine and it doesn't even have,
okay,
here's what's in this water.
Chicken,
pork liver.
That's all editable.
Brown rice,
carrots,
delish,
modified starch,
wheat flour,
potato starch,
pork plasma.
What's pork?
Plasma dried beet pulp.
Potatoes.
Get involved,
but I think it is Quito.
No,
listen,
there's good stuff in here.
Okay.
Mac,
magnus sulfate,
potassium vitamins,
e supplement.
Okay,
so this isn't bad.
Lic.
And I take,
I take all this stuff.
The fans await you.
What do you think?
Okay,
okay.
Okay.
How big of a bite though.
You don't have to have just a little chunk.
Gut.
Yeah.
I was on road rules guys.
I was on road roles.
I can do this
chunky.
How about if I,
do I have to eat a piece of meat or can I just taste the gravy?
How about I just taste,
taste the gravy.
Is that enough?
Right?
Yeah.
Well,
let me just taste the cause that's kind of what I'm curious.
Did the meat looks like Tofu?
It doesn't even look like real meat,
but the gravy,
it does smell delicious,
I have to say.
Okay.
Uh,
and he hit me in the ring.
Yes,
definitely.
Aye,
go ahead.
Okay.
Ready?
Yup.
Yeah.
It's on the tongue on the tongue.
How bad,
how bad.
Your eyes are a little watery,
watery.
It's like bad picture.
John Soccer's taking his it,
you know what?
It's not,
it's not terrible.
Yeah,
it's not,
you know what it tastes like.
Like,
uh,
Vietnamese food
that's so insulting,
so incredibly offensive to like our Vietnamese friends.
Like,
oh no.
Kind of like that oyster sauce like that.
The smell of oyster sauce.
Like it's kind of actually making my eyes water.
Not Terrible.
Not Great.
Okay.
You got your ring.
Don't worry about it.
Yes.
Oh,
this email just not bad.
Just saw this email now.
Oh,
you nasty.
Why?
Give me some nasty Tom.
You Ready?
Yeah,
and put that down.
I can't believe I just put that up.
Subject
line says x Dude,
ex dog food manufacturer here.
Don't do it.
Tina,
do you like bro?
I heard your podcast today and heard about the dog food challenge.
No dog food isn't low grade meet.
It is the last thing left from an animal that can be salvaged.
I worked in a huge slaughterhouse in Texas 20 years ago and I work in the
rendering department.
All of the guts,
heads,
shit,
et Cetera is cooked up to make the raw material of dog food.
Also,
everything is washed down the drains and we cooked that to the water would be
placed in a huge tank.
The water,
we pay it in a huge tank of water and air would be bubbled up through that and
the fat would float to the top.
We would cook that up.
Two guys would throw their boots,
old knives flying cockroaches.
Rats under the algorithm gets cooked up.
All right.
You sold the Purina for dog food and we were behind in cooking.
We had the slaughter guys placed the heads into boxes to be cooked later.
Big boxes that hold probably 50 heads heads increase the cook time.
So that allowed us to catch up.
The boxes will be placed out in the sun.
We'd cook them on Sunday when the slaughter house isn't running.
These heads baked in the sun and became covered in maggots.
Okay.
I looked like they were covered.
They are moving from the thousands of magazine I'm going to throw out.
Thank you.
Yes.
Where that went.
All sold the period to make dog biscuits.
Don't ever eat dog food.
Oh boy.
It's all same two,
don't fall
for that fancy feast.
Bullshit.
It's all the same material we provided for you.
Reena.
Add some other ingredients.
Right?
But the raw material comes from the gutters of a slaughter house.
I uh,
I had attached a picture.
I have more if you want more proof hook.
So you attached a picture?
Yeah.
It looks like this is what I'm,
can I ask something to eat it?
Oh boy.
This is the floor.
Oh God,
I need something.
And you feel fine.
I mean,
not right now.
Not After hearing that.
Oh,
I'll eat like a peanut or something.
Yeah,
it's not that bad.
Don't eat the peanut because then it'll mess with what you ate for the FARC Chit
challenged.
Well,
your dog or your shit smelling like dog shit.
I think I've eaten a lot more before we can tell if my shit will smell like a
dog show.
Yeah,
that's true.
That's nasty dude.
You Nasty,
man.
I ain't no reason to be.
It doesn't taste that bad though.
Know?
You're like,
it's not,
it just tasted like a Vietnamese food.
Yeah.
Like um,
you keep going there.
Gravy.
Yeah.
Gravy is good.
All right.
Oh,
it's smelled okay.
I mean.
Mm hmm.
But the hard food,
I wouldn't eat the kibble.
The cabled nasty.
Yeah.
I wouldn't have done that.
I really wasn't thinking you would do that really well.
Not really.
I thought you would have put up more of a fight.
I was in Robert.
You stuck to your word.
Oh,
of course.
I was on railroads.
When were you on road roads?
Shut up.
Oh my God.
I want to take the physical challenge.
I was season four.
We were in Amsterdam.
What season were you on?
He never did an Amsterdam.
Yeah,
he did.
And he's a four.
We did.
Okay.
Of course.
I keep my word.
You think I'm going to chimp out on a fucking handshake.
Gill chimp out.
What's that mean?
Oh No,
I just came home,
but I don't know.
How proud are you?
Proud of you.
I'll get your lollipop ring today.
Thank you.
Yeah,
it wasn't that.
Honestly,
not that bad.
Really?
No.
Don't encourage people to do it though.
I'm not encouraging people with maggots and shit in it,
but yeah.
You know,
I've always been tempted now,
you know.
Okay.
I can,
I,
you know,
if someone falls on the ground,
you can just go down and look it up.
Don't have to waste it.
Ate Dog food.
Yeah.
It's so crazy.
Try it.
Do you want to try it?
What would it take for you to try it?
Nope,
just the gravy.
The gravy is good
to what's going on with our mouth.
We haven't been,
I haven't been to a dentist since we moved here.
Dennis,
you've got gotta go now.
I can't get the taste out of my mouth and dog food.
What if they go?
You've been eating too much dog food.
We got you have a lot of cavities and all that stuff.
I started getting into them.
Speaks food.
Oh,
there are carrots in it too.
We're guilty.
We're guilty as charged,
man.
We're not being good.
Well,
here's why I wanted to wait until we moved to the new neighborhood before I
start going two ways.
Why not just
wait and then go for a checkup?
What if they are like,
um,
if you've been eating,
you've got canine teeth now.
Thank you for this.
Uh,
lost him shit.
Speed.
Um,
let's,
uh,
let's read it.
A listener email here to my dears.
Mommy's.
I recently had my bottom wisdom teeth removed because they were impacted wisdom
teeth,
meaning that they grew in almost completely sideways.
Oh boy.
I had large pockets in which food would build up.
Yes,
I've had that.
I did absolutely everything to get rid of the amazing remaining food,
yet absolutely nothing could do the trick.
That being said,
there had to be infected,
right.
That had to be something.
I went to my local CVS bottled waterpik literally changed my life.
I keep hearing that about waterpiks.
I can be honest,
because I have veneers.
They pop right off.
Flossing is merely the hand job of dental hygiene.
I would highly recommend buying one,
especially one with a variety of different attachments.
Also,
I found that with a bit of mouthwash or hydrogen peroxide,
it will truly leave your mouth feeling Amaz love you mommies.
I hope that one day you'll be able to experience the wonder that is a waterpik.
I got to do this,
Nico.
Thanks Nico.
We had one at the old house.
I remember.
We have a countertop.
I can actually,
yeah,
it was too small,
but yeah.
Um,
thank you for the email.
Go to your mom's house,
podcast.com and order your waterpik through our Amazon banner.
Uh,
mommies.
I feel compelled to tell you one of the most insane dental updates I've ever
heard.
After dating my boyfriend for five years and hours of listening to you guys,
I finally gained the courage to tell him to go to the tennis.
Oh Wow.
And see how he can improve on his teeth.
We live in San Diego where we saw Tom at the American comedy club and Dennis and
Mexico are much,
much cheaper,
equally professional option.
He came back and said he has to get gum graphs onto his teeth.
Oh boy.
Here are the options.
Tissue from the roof of his mouth out,
graft it into the front of his teeth or from a fucking cadaver
mother fucking body.
I'm horrified to think that I'm kissing another person's mouth when he gets it
down,
but that's the sacrifice we're willing to make for a perfect smile.
Keeping it high and tight.
Come back to San Diego.
Audrey,
I got a compliment.
I got to commend you on saying something.
After five years,
that will ultimately make him feel better and look better.
You know,
it's hard to say those things.
She told him you should do something about your toothpaste.
It must have been pretty bad.
Bad.
If they need grafts and maybe they need to be boy.
Yeah,
but think about how hard it is for her to say something.
I know.
Just the thing you want to tell me.
Yeah.
Is that why you're bringing that up?
No,
I just think that it's commendable that like it's hard to do that and so I think
that's actually a loving thing to do.
I would definitely go for the,
the skin on my own mouth than a cadaver.
Right?
I Dunno.
I would have it explained to me very clear Spanish first.
Oh my God.
Maybe maybe not do it in Mexico.
I don't know.
I Dunno.
I don't know that that's not necessarily the truth.
I mean,
that's true.
There's a lot of,
there's a bunch of teeth down there.
That's true.
Maybe it's a,
maybe it's great.
I mean,
yeah,
it's gotta be hard to tell someone that for sure.
Uh,
yeah.
You hear how much better that one was?
You know what I did there?
I didn't force it.
Just let it kind of interesting.
Very Zen approach.
Yeah.
Hold on.
How's the dog food burp?
Oh,
hi.
No maggots in you right now because I feel weird.
I didn't,
I didn't like that.
Like all the other stuff that he said didn't bother me until I heard the
maggots.
Ooh.
Now I'm,
I'm trying not to think about it that I just ate dog food with maggots in it.
This is something I've always wanted to ask about.
I've never known about this.
I another email came in how to massage my wife for longer than two seconds.
It says,
after an unpleasant experience,
having my wisdom teeth removed when I was 18 and having sworn off at Dennis last
week before my 29th birthday,
I decided it was time to go back for a checkup after one of my back molars
turned brown.
Oh,
oh.
I brushed my teeth once in the morning.
I'm very good about flossing throughout the day,
but after 11 years of smoking and negligence,
all I needed was a deep cleaning in two fillings.
The brown tooth was due to me not having an adult tooth come in and the baby
tooth started to die.
Oh,
I've seen that.
There's nothing I could've done about it.
They said they can pull it out if it starts to turn to hurt down the line.
All of this costs me $100 what may then it's these days we'll cut you a huge
deal if you become a member of their office,
which for me is $5 a month.
Wow.
And we'll usually also throw in a free whitening kit.
Thank you mommy for helping me toughen up and make the appointment.
My tea firs are so much prettier now and my jeans have never been higher.
Tighter.
Stephen,
I want to say this too.
First of all,
we are on the fucking line that we have to do something.
I need to go get her to fees clean.
We do.
Secondly,
yeah.
I've had friends of mine.
Tell me with regard to other medical things they needed,
if you're like,
oh,
I need to have this done,
I don't have the insurance.
Yeah.
I know doctors many times we'll make a deal for you if you pay cash.
So you walk in and you just go,
I need whatever,
whatever.
Yeah.
Whatever,
whatever.
A lot of times doctors will make a deal with you.
Well,
I'll tell you when,
uh,
we got the panel of retard tests for Ellis when I was pregnant.
Yeah.
They want to charge us thousands of dollars and I called the company and I go,
we don't have that money.
Yeah.
They go,
can you pay 300?
Yeah,
yeah,
sure,
sure.
So it's all negotiable guys.
All negotiable.
Yeah.
Um,
just yeah,
you just have to protest,
you know what I mean?
Anything else?
Jeans?
Um,
let's see.
We did dog food.
Hmm.
Silo domain.
High Water Flask.
No,
I think we're good.
All right.
And have leeway to try dog food.
I never thought I would.
Now you've got to see if it affects your farm.
Have you take a dog dump that we know it's a,
it's a great hypothesis that somebody put out there.
Maybe that's why their shit smell so bad cause it's all maggots and rotten stuff
that they,
hopefully next week I'll be able to play you some clips from not just
[inaudible].
I gotta get ready.
I have to go get ready to go get ready.
You got to brush up on your Spanish.
Yeah.
All right.
Um,
thank you for listening.
I love you.
Here's the kick my balls.
I Dj Orlando Airport and those are closing song.
Bye guys.
Hey Mommy.
Pick me as hard as you can in the mall.
Hard as you can.
Oh,
okay.
Oh that's good.
Yeah.
Good.
Going up against,
up against,
get up against the walls like July.
Yeah.
Take me as hard as you can in the balls.
Kick me as hard as you gain in the balls.
Oh,
oh,
oh fuck boy.
Oh,
you're scum.
fucking Domini fucking dummy.
Good
fucking dummy.
Come here.
Scump
fucking dumb.
Fuck boy.
Boy.